[Music]
[Music]
Patrick I thought of something funnier
than 24 maybe hear it 25 last we checked
you lived in a pineapple under the sea
spongebob you probably the last cartoon
character we would ever expect to see a
doppelganger for after all your yellow
and rectangular but sometimes strange
things happen yes spongebob we've even
found your real life look-alike and we
have to say the resemblance is pretty
uncanny cartoons aren't always realistic
but every now and then we find someone
who looks like a favorite character he's
watching for 10 cartoon characters that
were spotted in real life Dora the
Explorer you don't need your special
backpack or a magical map to find Dora
the Explorer Dora is a beloved character
from our preschool days who doesn't love
the girl who taught us Spanish through
adventures but we never expected to see
her in real life sis photo was snapped
on public transit this little girl is
just so cute with her Dora haircut she
is even wearing a pink top like our
favorite Explorer do you think she has a
purple backpack Carl from up up is one
of the sweetest Pixar movies of all time
we love that grumpy Karl learned how to
be happy again
thanks to a little boy a talking dog and
an exotic bird he was voiced by Ed Asner
but there appears to be someone who
looks identical to Carl the nose and the
chin are exactly the same he's got the
same smile as Carl too with those
glasses it looks like Carl jumped right
off that screen and into the real world
Alfredo from ratatouille who can forget
the awkward cook alfredo linguine he's
afraid of losing his job so he makes
friends with a rat named Remy who is a
gourmet chef but it looks like Alfredo
has a real-life counterpart take a look
at this guy he is the same curly hair
his nose looks almost identical
he even has a similarly shaped face it's
hard to believe how close the
resemblance is we wonder how he feels
about rats Andy from Toy Story 3 ok this
next vote
was definitely posed but we can totally
see why in Toy Story 3 Andy is headed
off to college he is a lot more grown-up
than he was in the first two movies it's
okay this guy realized he looks a lot
like teenage Andy he has similar hair
and eyes so he posed just like Andy
alongside Buzz and Woody it could be a
live-action version of Toy Story 3 Shrek
now we aren't saying that ogre czar real
we would be really freaked out if we saw
a green guy with eager ears walking down
the street take a look at this historic
photo of a wrestler from the 1930s and
40s Maurice Tillet was named the French
angel he looks a lot like Shrek the nose
and eyes are spot-on it's actually
possible that Tillett was the
inspiration for stripes design and let's
not forget the wrestling style scene
from the first track movie when he takes
down farquaad's champions the frozen
sisters
this next look-alike is a perfect mix
between both Elsa and honest look at
this woman she spotted an Elsa cutout
and posed with that signature smirk not
only are their faces similar but she's
also wearing this same color eyeshadow
and blush as Elsa but she isn't a
platinum blonde that red hair makes her
look a lot like onna - maybe she's a
long-lost sister of the arendelle
royalty Russell from up we have not one
but two characters from Pixar's up in
this video it's not just Carl
we found the real-life Russell and it
looks like his family saw the
resemblance - they dressed him up just
like the Scout character he's even got
the sash full of badges and the yellow
hat we can't believe how adorable this
photo is we pet this kid could also turn
a grumpy old man into a nice guy
Rapunzel's the feisty princess with
magic hair is another fan favorite it's
probably impossible to find someone with
the same length of hair but we did find
someone who looks pretty similar actress
Amanda Seyfried from Mean Girls and
Mamma Mia resembles Rapunzel a lot
they're both blonde with
our mouths and noses but we think it's
those huge green eyes that really seal
the deals and Amanda usually plays
characters with bubbly personalities
just like Rapunzel mallanna mallanna
quickly became one of the most popular
Disney Princesses and for good reason
she's a go-getter with a great storyline
and her songs are awesome
now Moana already looks a lot like the
actress who voiced her alii crevalle oh
but that's not the only celebrity who
resembles the Polynesian princess fans
have been quick to point out that the
singer and songwriter
Alessia Cara looks a lot like Moana and
we totally see it she has very similar
facial features and the same dark curly
hair spongebob squarepants spongebob
squarepants is a classic cartoon
character he's been around for a very
long time and is definitely the last
cartoon character we ever expected to
see in real life here we are
this person is wrapped in yellow foam we
can only see their legs we seriously
have so many questions
where's the rest of the person or is it
a short kid why are they wrapped in foam
are they okay they're just laying there
which cartoon character would you love
to meet in real life don't be shy let us
know in the comments Halloween is
usually the perfect time to show people
how you'd look like dressed as your
favorite cartoon character but some of
these kids didn't need to wait until
Halloween to show us they are totally
twinning with cartoon characters are you
ready for the insane amount of cuteness
give this video a big thumbs up if you
still love watching cartoons today we're
discussing ten kids who twin with
cartoon characters Darla dimple
look-alike do you remember honey booboo
the hyperactive beauty pageant girl from
Toddlers and Tiaras who became world
famous and got her own spin-off show
ever thought she looks similar to a
cartoon character we think she really
does look like Darla dimple from the
cats don't dance movie look at them
they're totally twinning without even
realizing it Darla's character is a
surprisingly similar upbeat personality
to Alana's although to our knowledge
Darla doesn't need any go-go juice to
stay hyper looking at this picture can
you spot the similarities to curly hair
the adorable layered tutu
dress and of course they're both wearing
their signature pink color Alana's fame
started with an episode of toddlers and
tiaras when she was just six years old
her over-the-top sassy personality
captured the world and her toddlers in
tiaras segment quickly went viral
nicknamed honey boo boo Alana quickly
got her own spin-off show which was on
air for four seasons the reality TV show
world is nothing new for this little
firecracker but if she ever decided it
was time to test her acting her
voiceover skills Darla dimple might just
be the perfect character for this honey
boo boo child boo look-alike is boo your
favorite monsters ink character we can't
blame you she's absolutely adorable the
black haired big eyed cute little
toddler stole the hearts of many
including this little girls who might as
well be her human twin she looks like
she's the biggest monsters ink fan ever
look at her holding her Mike Wazowski
and Sulley
did you know boos real name is actually
Mary she never tells her name out loud
but if you look closely you can see that
a name Mary is signed repeatedly on boos
drawings Mary Gibbs is also the name of
the actress who gave boo her cute voice
here's what Mary Gibbs looked like when
she was playing boo at just five years
old and here's what she looks like now
as a college freshman she said she can't
do a cute voice of boo anymore but don't
worry this boo look-alike seems like
she's ready to continue the Monsters Inc
legacy we love that her pink hair bands
even have the exact same detail as boos
and she even has matching pigtails
what's your favorite boo monsters ink
moment ours is still the first time she
met Sully and called him kitty
Russell look-alike the movie up would
definitely not be the same without
Russell the curious and hyper wilderness
explorer Russell charmed everyone with
his personality and his unique look he's
adorably chubby dressed in his
wilderness explorer outfit which
includes a scout neckerchief and tons of
gadgets in his twice a size backpack his
look and personality are so unique
there's no way there would be a
real-life person out there who would
look just like Russell right wrong check
out this little guy standing in front of
the up poster if there's anyone who
would get a badge of the Russell
look-alike it would definitely be him
how cute is that
did you know that Russell was originally
named
Louis the story team thought his name
would cause confusion with the Meet the
Robinsons character if you ever wondered
how Russell managed to sound so cute
throughout the movie you can thank his
voice actor who would sometimes run
around before saying a line Jordan a guy
might not look like Russell from up but
this kid sure fits the description of
everyone's favorite wilderness explorer
this has to be one of our favorite
cartoon character look-alikes ever now
all we need is Carl in the real-life
version of up we'll be complete linguini
look-alike if ratatouille is your
favorite Disney movie get ready for this
amazing accidental look-alike what do
you think could he pass as linguine
maybe it's the curly hair or his funny
pose on the photo but he is definitely
twinning with linguini the not so
talented ratatouille chef in the movie
linguini is very unsure in clumsy which
are the two traits no chef should ever
have but linguini was also very
kind-hearted and gentle which instantly
made us fall in love with him it seems
like this kid just needs a chef's outfit
and a hat and you'll be looking at a
human version of linguini we just hope
he's not as clumsy in the kitchen we
wonder if he has any pets like rats for
example or would that just take it too
far did you know that linguini is
actually a form of pasta and its actual
name means little tongues speaking of
ratatouille the very final dish served
to Anton ego in the movie was actually
created by a real-life chef called
Thomas Keller who owns a world-famous
restaurant in Napa Valley
that you're craving some ratatouille
right now do you think the boy in this
picture learned how to make the famous
dish eggs look alike
twinning with cartoon characters is not
an easy task usually they come with over
exaggerated features that go far beyond
human inspiration but for some reason
these kids keep on surprising us we're
halfway through the video but don't you
go anywhere because the next kid is too
cute for words and so is his cartoon
twin remember boxtrolls the 2014 movie
about the orphan called eggs who saves
the community of boxtrolls from
extermination it's a pretty unusual
movie but it has super adorable
characters and if you're into cute
looking monsters then this is definitely
a movie you should see who would have
thought that a kid could look exactly
like eggs well it turns out it's
possible check out this picture perhaps
is his eyes his teeth or maybe his
but this little kid surely looks a lot
like boxtrolls --is eggs eggs got his
name from the label on the box he wears
his clothes just like all the other
boxtrolls but unlike everyone else eggs
actually speaks English because of his
speech impediment compared to most
animations out there this is definitely
a unique movie with even better
characters who can resist the look of
eggs and his new human twin Dora the
Explorer look-alike get ready more
cuteness incoming we bet you know
someone who's a huge Dora the Explorer
fan Dora the Explorer first premiered on
Nickelodeon in August 2000 and no one
could imagine that this spanish-speaking
little girl
would soon take over the world kids were
completely head over heels in love with
her character and soon they were able to
buy Dora the Explorer toys backpacks
books games party accessories and of
course costumes but some kids are lucky
they don't need to dress up like Dora
because they already look like her
check out this cutie with her gorgeous
Bob Banks and an adorable pink outfit
now there's someone who doesn't really
need to dress up like Dora she could
very well be her human look-alike Dora
the Explorer is known to be one of the
most popular educational programs for
kids the show has been such a hit a 1
quite a few awards including a Daytime
Emmy and NAACP Image Award for
outstanding children's program but apart
from that you can also find plenty of
award templates on the actual Dora
website where you can give yourself or
your friend a pat on the back
we definitely give our award to this
cute Dora look-alike Andy look-alike who
can forget about Andy Davis the owner of
all your favorite Toy Story characters
Andy is just a normal looking kid who
really loves his toys especially woody
well at least until he gets Buzz
Lightyear woody gets jealous of Buzz and
the two toys get lost when their family
has to move and the rest of the story is
history want to hear something that will
make you feel old Toy Story was 20 years
old in 2015 there's a constant debate
over who's the best Toy Story character
is it Hamm slinky dog Rex woody or Buzz
you decide and it looks like it's a hard
decision for Andy Davis's very own human
like check out this kid holding his very
own Woody and Buzz toys just like his
cartoon look-alike does in the movie his
hair and his facial features are
remarkably similar to Andy and it looks
like the two are totally twinning have
you ever noticed that actually all kids
from Toy Story have Andy's face no
really
rewatch the birthday party scene and
you'll notice everyone pretty much looks
the same looks like the toy stories have
a few more look-alikes not only the
human world but also in other cartoon
characters Phil's de Ville look-alike
get ready to go off when we show you the
next picture and if you think it's
totally impossible for anyone to look
like Phil de Ville you might want to
rethink your statement check out this
kid rocking the haircut adorable Phil de
Ville is a 1 year old toddler in the
Rugrats movie and television show and
he's a sister named lil they're always
matching and we wonder if this human
look-alike also has a twin sister who
knows they might get the part in the
next Rugrats movie the two might just be
the greatest twins in TV history as they
somehow manage to look cool in every
single cartoon episode remember when
they starred in a diaper commercial or
the time they were dressed in this and
someone from tumblr commented if that's
Johnny Depp and Helena Bonham Carter
well we're pretty sure this little
gentleman looks mighty fine in every
outfit he's wearing too and who knows
you might be speaking gibberish to you
but you never know what this rug rat is
really up to kudos to you kid it's not
easy to look like Phil Deville who's
your favorite Rugrats character Phil
Deville is definitely winning our hearts
Moana look-alike and one of the biggest
surprises when it comes to cartoon
look-alikes is without a doubt alii
Cavallo she is a 14 year old from Hawaii
whose voice is just as magical as her
looks doesn't she look like a real-life
princess in fact doesn't she look
exactly like Moana the resemblance is
striking but that's not even the most
fascinating part of this Hawaiian
princesses story the Disney characters
looks weren't even based on her Ali was
actually the very last girl that
auditioned for the part of Moana after
she was discovered by casting agents she
actually thought there was no way she
would even be considered for the role
alii is the youngest actress to ever
give a Disney Princess a voice and she
has the honour to play the first-ever
Polynesian princess how cool is that
it's
absolutely amazing how much she looks
like the actual princess in every sense
including her hair mallanna's hair was
designed so precisely the team behind
the movie had to introduce brand new
tools and software to make her hair
realistic but it looks like Ally's hair
is just as fabulous we're pretty sure
the two are secretly twins and there's
definitely no other person out there who
could play Moana as amazingly as Ali
does Agnes look-alike if you didn't
think boo from Monsters Inc was cute
wait until you see our next cartoon twin
give this video a thumbs up if
Despicable Me is your favorite movie
because we're just about to show you the
cutest kid who twinned with Agnes check
her out rocking the exact hairstyle and
clothes the youngest of the despicable
Me sisters trio is arguably one of the
most adorable characters ever all she
wants is a fluffy unicorn and she holds
her breath until she gets her way
Agnes is your typical six-year-old and
she really is completely unicorn crazy
her unique haircut looks like it could
be very hard to style so we give huge
kudos to her human look-alike from the
fluffy red hairband to the two strands
on each side of her head this girl got
the Agnes hairstyle down to a tee her
yellow shirt and denim overalls the
little heart in the middle are perfect
and look at that sassy pose you go
girlfriend if you want to see what Agnes
would look like as an adult make sure
you check out the part 2 of our ten kid
cartoon characters reimagined as adults
it looks like she'd still be just as
unicorn crazy as she was when she was
six how many times have you wanted to
dress up as your favorite cartoon
character we can't blame you they're
absolutely the coolest these next 10
kids didn't need to put much effort into
their looks they already look like some
of your favorite cartoon characters
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more videos like this and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up now
join us as we take a look at ten cartoon
characters based on real children the
boss baby look-alike oh my goodness can
you say cuteness overload we just melt
every time we see a kid in a suit how
cute is this check out this little
blue-eyed and blond haired guy totally
rockin his outfit does he look familiar
to you have you seen the new 2017 movie
the boss baby we think this kid could
play the human version of the boss baby
if you're not familiar with the movie
here's all you need to know
the boss baby as the name suggests acts
like a total boss well come to think of
it name one baby that doesn't but the
boss baby has the whole package
he's even dressed in a fancy suit he
carries a briefcase and he needs to
discover why babies are losing their
market share of love he also thinks
puppies are evil and his brothers
convinced he's taking over the whole
house this is the cutest plot line ever
the boss baby is voiced by Alec Baldwin
but this little kid looks like he's his
own version of the boss baby the white
collar the black tie and the suit Oh
can things get any cuter than this
whether it's accidental or not these two
babies are totally hashtag twinning and
he's not the only boss baby out there
the little guy on the right might as
well be the real boss baby Peter Griffin
look-alike now it's very hard to look
like Peter Griffin but this next kid
seems to have the look totally down and
he looks very proud of it what do you
think could Peter Griffin actually be
based on this boy although he could
definitely play the younger version of
one of the family guys main characters
the real Peter Griffin was actually
based on a man called Paul Timmins if
you've ever seen Family Guy you know
that the show features some very
over-the-top personalities Peter Griffin
portrays the typical sitcom dad who
doesn't really know what to do with
himself besides not to get in the way
and mess things up it doesn't always
work but that does give us some of the
most hilarious scenes Paul Timmins the
man behind Peter is a Rhode Island
native just like the show itself and its
creator Paul was a security guard on
Seth MacFarlane's school campus
MacFarlane described it as having a
thick accent with absolutely no filter
and that's exactly what Peter Griffin
brings to the Family Guy table well if
they're ever in need of a young human
version of Peter Griffin it's safe to
say that this young man could easily
play the part Bobby from king of the
hill look-alike this might be a
completely accidental take but don't you
think this kid really looks like Bobby
from the king of the hill cartoon the
show was on air from 1997 to 2010 and it
has quite an impressive fan base behind
it it's actually the second longest
animated series right behind The
Simpsons the four-foot-tall Bobby isn't
the main character of the story but he
definitely has some amazing moments that
easily make him a favorite his full name
is Robert Jeffrey Hill and he's voiced
by
Adlon Bobby's not really good at sports
even though his athletic dad wants him
to be he's kind and has a soft
personality and he can easily charm
girls we love his buzz cut which you can
also see on his human look-alike not
much is known about the child on the
right but he definitely fit right in the
king of the hill series king of the hill
and the Simpsons are the two longest
standing cartoon shows and you can find
many crossover references in both shows
Bobby even has a Bart Simpson doll on
his bookshelf what do you think could
this child pass as Bobby who's your
favorite king of the hill character let
us know in the comments below
boo look-alike pigtails check adorable
check hanging out with monsters check
named one little girl who wouldn't want
to look like the adorable gibberish
talking boo from Monsters Inc give this
video a thumbs up if boo is one of your
favorite characters we can't blame you
if she is she's absolutely adorable
although it might seem really hard to
twin with a cutie like booth Saint
pigtails same pink rubber bands and same
pink shirt she even has the same big
eyes as boo boo was originally played by
Mary Gibbs and it has been noted that
Mary might be the monsters ink child's
actual name do you remember when boo was
going to sleep on Sully's bed and
there's a brief moment when she shows a
drawing if you look at the sign to
drawing you'll notice she spells her
name as Mary although the real Mary is
blond this adorable boo look-alike could
very easily play the part of being Mike
and Sully's protege if she ever had a
chance her outfit might not really be
accidental she looks like she's a huge
Monsters Inc fan if the makers of
Monsters Inc ever needed a human version
of boo this little girl would win that
audition hands-down Humpty Dumpty
look-alike you look like Humpty Dumpty
isn't usually the best kind of
compliment you could give to someone but
when you're this cute looking like a
cartoon character just makes things a
million times better Humpty Dumpty is
the story of an egg looking thing that
belongs in English Nursery Rhymes
you know the rhyme right Humpty Dumpty
sat on a wall Humpty Dumpty had a great
fall and so on and so on since then this
egg also became a cartoon character
frequently featured in comics and while
he might not be as loved as some of the
other cartoon characters on our list
trying to look like him might be quite a
challenge for some people unless you're
this little guy who might as well be his
human twin check out those big eyes the
bowtie and the white
all he's missing is a hat and the role
of the fallen egg would be his
although the famous egg was definitely
not based on this little cutie he should
be all we need to see now is the blue
pants yellow striped shirt a red suit
and the snazzy black hat there are many
theories of the eggs origin out there
but we'll be happy to take the theory
that this little guy is somehow
connected to Humpty Dumpty Zootopia
flash look-alike someone pointed out
that the girl on the left looks very
similar to flash from Zootopia remember
him
flash was the fastest sloth working at
the Department of mammal vehicles in the
2016 Zootopia movie of course as a sloth
everything he does is still very slow
compared to everyone else except for
maybe sales although they don't belong
in this story so what do you think of
this comparison is the internet just
joking around or does this girl really
look like flash perhaps it's just a
weird coincidence but we really do see
it flash is a three-toed sloth with
perpetually droopy eyelids a light green
shirt and a dark blue tie although the
girl on the Left clearly isn't wearing
any of Flash's clothing it's her facial
expressions that are giving the true
flash vibes even her mouth is exactly
the same the droopy eyelids the slightly
fascinated look it's all there do you
think this was a planned photo how did
someone even figure out that she looks
like the animated sloth working at the
DMV Oh Internet never change who's your
favorite character in Zootopia make sure
you let us know in the comments below
Agnes look-alike if we learned anything
from this video it's that you can find
some of the most adorable kids looking
like their favorite cartoon characters
and sometimes they don't even realize
they're doing it but this look-alike
might not be so accidental it's not easy
looking identical to Agnes from
Despicable Me but this little girl comes
pretty close who would have thought a
human would be able to put her hair up
in the same way as AG 'no studs agnes is
the youngest of the three orphans who
get to live with GRU and make him find
the true meaning of family
she's crazy obsessed with unicorns and
we're still sad that her caterpillar
never turned into a butterfly well it
looks like Agnes has a human look like
walking around the world this adorable
cutie really managed to perfect her look
from the haircut with bangs to those
amazing denim overalls with a yellow
shirt what do you think could she fit
right in the despicable Me family all
we're missing now is GRU
her two sisters and of course minions
although we might think that finding a
human version of minions might be the
hardest part of the process we wish this
Agnes look-alike
many fluffy unicorns and even more toys
frozen's Elsa look-alike it's hard to
have the same features as any Disney
Princess but some people are lucky
enough to look just like them the
resemblance between Elsa and this lady
is uncanny
although she's not a child anymore this
Elsa look-alike was just 18 when people
started noticing just how much she looks
like everyone's favorite ice princess
perhaps is the eye makeup or maybe just
that smirk but there's something about
her that makes you think she could
easily play a part in Disney's movie
frozen well you're not the only one who
thinks she's a perfect Elsa look-alike
her name is Anna faith and she's a well
known Elsa cosplayer she pulls it off so
well she's actually been able to make
money from her Disney based looks she
portrayed Elsa on the TV series Access
Hollywood and she's one of the most
popular cosplayers she's even gotten her
sister to dress up as Anna and the two
managed to gain international popularity
they were even invited to attend a royal
party in the United Arab Emirates the
two are absolutely stunning if Disney
ever needed to recreate frozen they now
have a complete package collab rant as
Kristoff and Anna and Lexi Carlson as
Elsa and Anna all we need now is Olaf
and were all ready to let it go
marg champion as Snow White did you know
that Snow White was actually based on a
real person her name is Marge champion
and she was one of the best dancers of
the 20th century not only was she
insanely talented she was also very
beautiful in fact she was so beautiful
Disney took her to model for many of
their characters including Snow White
she was just 14 at the time the same age
as Snow White the creator's wanted to
redesign the princess for the 1937 movie
and Marge had to wear a helmet so they
were able to envision snow white with a
larger head Walt Disney was hiding the
fact they used Marge as a Disney model
for quite a few years before the secret
was finally revealed now Marge is 97
years old and she's still one of the
most inspiring people behind Disney she
even said it herself that she had a very
interesting life and we must agree so
what do you think do you see the
resemblance between Snow White and Marge
since her role she became quite
Hollywood famous and performed in
musicals such as showboat give a
lebryk and three for the show Alyssa
Milano as Ariel if there's a queen of
Disney princesses that's possibly bigger
than marge champion it's probably Alyssa
Milano
you might remember Alyssa for her role
as Phoebe Halliwell in charm but the
truth was she was recognized way before
that role did you know that Alyssa was
actually a model for Disney's Princess
Ariel when she was just 16 and she
didn't even know it at the time she
reveals her secret in 2013 but the
resemblance between her and the Little
Mermaid was spotted ever since the movie
came out an animator took Alyssa's who's
the boss look and created everyone's
favorite Disney mermaid what do you
think do you see it although Ariel
clearly has amazingly red hair the
resemblance between the two is striking
Sherri stoner an actress and a writer
was brought in to showcase Ariel's
movements so in theory if you combine
Alyssa Milano's looks and Sherri stoners
moves you'll get Ariel did you know that
Sherri stoner was also used a model for
Belle Disney is full of surprises when
it comes to taking inspiration from
other human beings who knows maybe there
are even more actors out there who
served as an inspiration for Disney
characters which cartoon character is
your absolute favorite let us know in
the comments don't forget to subscribe
and make sure you give this video a
thumbs up for more videos like this
check out 10 kids cartoon logic fails
that make no sense see you next time bye
bye